western allies say they've extracted
more than a hundred thousand people from
afghanistan in recent weeks including
citizens diplomats the military and some
of their afghan staff almost half of the
evacuees transferred through doha in the
gulf state qatar some are still there
uncertain if they'll stay or be moved on
in search of a new home dw correspondent
rebecca ritters reports
in the blistering heat at doha's
al-udaid air base this giant c-17 rolls
to a stop
with it the end of a chaotic life-saving
evacuation effort
but the cargo on this final flight from
afghanistan just some equipment and a
few journalists
qatar's civilian evacuation over for now
for many of those that came before
though this is their temporary home
muhammad mustafa was one of those able
to make it out by way of qatar he
escaped with six of his family members
like so many others they were caught
unawares when the taliban took control
of kabul
my mother suddenly called me that you
have to get to
home faster
at the first call i would
be okay i will come but
my mother that day about
10 calls that i had from my mother
because they all were scared
though now safe he's sad when he thinks
of the loved ones he was forced to leave
behind it's really hard for everyone
that you leave your friends and even
don't say goodbye to them
we had to tell nobody so i don't
tell my best friends even
it's a familiar story among those here
as relief gives way to guilt
mariam s also made it out with her
family but worries for those left back
at home
i'm just heartbroken you know even
though i have made it out of afghanistan
but my heart is broken i whenever i
think about my people my relatives my
friends who are stuck in afghanistan and
they're like caged at their homes they
don't know what to do so
i feel very bad for everyone
more than 40 000 evacuees have passed
through doha since the airlift began
qatar has served as a key transit point
and the government here has been helping
in any way it can
since the evacuation they've been fully
supplied with there's a health cleaning
on site there are activities for the
kids there's
ongoing you know stock rooms that are
filling up to make sure that people have
access to whatever they need because a
lot of people have come in either with
you know very few items or even no items
at all
most people are waiting to be
transferred to third countries mariam
doesn't yet know where she'll end up but
dreams of the day she'll be able to
return home
i don't know if if there is still you
know hope to think that one day
everything will get fine for everybody
including those who have left
afghanistan and i promise if things get
better i'll be the first you know to fly
back to my country
for now though she and the others here
have to make the most of an uncertain
future
dw correspondent rebecca ritters who
filmed that report now joins me from
doha hey rebecca what's going to happen
to the tens of thousands of people
who've been evacuated to qatar
well michael as i mentioned in the
report qatar has served as a sort of
intermediary a sort of conduit people
are coming here they're filling out
their applications doing their pcr
testing all that kind of stuff obviously
the coronavirus has made the evacuations
even harder
from here most of them will be
transferred to third countries countries
like the us germany
and canada being key locations but lots
of other countries also taking in many
refugees
more than 50 percent of the some of the
40 000 or so people that have already
come to doha have been already
sorry resettled elsewhere and for those
that are still here more will be coming
in the following days
there will be some that will stay here
in doha but that number's still unclear
poignant stories i'm sure everywhere
there we've already heard from some of
the evacuees in your report
what else have they been telling you
it's a tragedy i i don't know how else
to describe it michael talking to these
people and hearing their stories uh is
nothing short of a tragedy really um
they really speak of the heartbreak of
leaving the country i tried to convey
that in the report because whilst they
feel really lucky to be able to be in
safety now they of course
are very passionate people they're very
patriotic people they love their country
and they they really all the people i
spoke to said that they were just
heartbroken not just to leave the
country itself but also the people that
they've had to leave behind there's also
a growing sense of guilt um if i could
put it like that in that many people who
are now safe really fear for their
friends and family back at home so it's
a devastating uh
situation and of course lots of tears
shed in those storytelling qatar clearly
playing a key role at least in some
phase of this story how important is
qatar when it comes to facilitating
dialogue with the taliban
well qatar have played a key role
facilitating dialogue with the taliban
long before the takeover a short while
ago um they have been
hosting the taliban here in qatar in
doha for many years at the request of
the us and they've been holding um
lots of talks between between the
taliban and western nations as well as
intra-afghan talks with the afghan
government they obviously didn't go that
well as we've seen in the past few weeks
um but it has been a very key role
they've also played a key role in the
evacuations there's obviously had to be
negotiations with the taliban in order
to get the people that have been able to
get out out
and of course going forward qatar say
that they are still willing to try and
evacuate more people and continue those
negotiations to try and evacuate people
after that thirty first u s deadline
that may be essential that's uh rebecca
ritters from doha many thanks rebecca
for more on the humanitarian situation
in afghanistan i'm joined now by chris
meltzer from the u.n refugee agency or
unhcr here in berlin welcome back to dw
chris we've just heard there from
evacuees that they're worried about
those left behind what are the
conditions those displaced people still
inside the country are facing
some of them are really dire conditions
so we have about 3.5 million refugees
within the country so internal displaced
persons afghans who are
in afghanistan
and who are kind of refugees idps and
many of them are very dire conditions
that's why we're trying to help them
we have a small number of people who
could
could return but many of them are now
and we are facing soon fall and winter
are
need indeed international help urgently
you mentioned dire conditions what
exactly do you mean by that just paint a
picture for me
many flared from their homes and they
have sometimes nothing only what they're
wearing or what they could carry um and
that's it many of them are with
relatives yes
but
there are thousands maybe tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands who
are who are without really support and
they need a roof they need clean water
they need food
that's what we try to provide but we
can't reach all of them
and what's the challenge uh the un
refugee agency faces as western allies
and their evacuations the uk of course
being one of the latest
well one challenge is of course that the
the country is now less secure and this
is also uh infrastructure problems um
like um giving the the trucks the
lorries with the help to the people the
other thing is the sheer number again
3.5 million
internal displaced persons so we are not
even talking about refugees outside of
afghanistan just the people inside
afghanistan this is already an enormous
challenge for for united nations and
other
relief organizations i suppose another
challenge is the decision about whether
you leave as well i mean will your
agency also leave the country
no we will stay stay and deliver that's
uh that's what we say uh i mean they are
most needed now uh we are in afghan
afghanistan for more than 40 years and
we were the the last 20 years we were
there also in the 90s when the taliban
already ruled afghanistan and
it is our intention to stay and to help
these people because they really need
our support and this is by the way our
mandate so we were made for situations
like that
that is a chris meltzer from the un
refugee agency many many thanks chris